- It was the craziest moment of my life.
I sat there on the phone and...
(heavy electronic beat)
(soft keyboard music)
I'll tell you, I'll tell you.
I'm good at patterns.
The same way that when I was an influencer
on Twitter and YouTube in
2006, there was no money,
but now Logan Paul can
make $40 million in a year,
that's what's gonna happen.
Netflix treated it like a movie
the way movies open in theatrical.
They get a movie, put it on Netflix
and then they spent money on television
and outdoor and all that.
Then all the kids - the King
Bach's, the Logans, all them -
they thought they could
make movies like this.
They made direct to iTunes and this,
and those didn't work either, right?
Same old shit.
It's just the same reason that
Tila Tequila and Dane Cook
used Myspace, got theirs,
but it's not the same level
of what the economics are now
for somebody that really wins.
Fat Jewish makes a lot more
money than Tila Tequila
even though it was the
same game 10 years apart.
The best thing I could do for you
from a pay it forward standpoint
is tell you why not to settle into your...
I do it and that's why I'm starting
to get better at my career.
- Settle into what you...
Know what you know.
- Get educated on how much
the world is your oyster.
Fame is the ultimate
arbitrage in our society.
My entire career,
and I'm not joking,
is predicated on what I learned
in selling baseball cards.
I'm not joking.
This entire company and all it's success
literally points back to baseball cards.
- [Arthur] Where are my royalties?
- Well how much do I owe you?
- Well, that's okay.
- It was the craziest moment of my life.
I sat there on the phone,
and you know how your brain
can go really fast sometimes?
- [Arthur] Yes, I do.
- And I was in an
interesting point of my life
because I invested in Facebook early on
so this was a realistic conversation.
And it ran through my mind of,
"My God, I came to this fucking country.
"I barely bought my
first pack of '83 Topps.
"Could barely buy a pack,
and I'm on a conversation
"right now to buy the whole fuckin' thing?
"This is the craziest shit ever."
- [Arthur] It's super iconic.
- [Gary] Ryan, two seconds.
Come here. Come here.
You are not going to
believe who this man is.
- Don't look at me.
- You're not gonna believe this.
- Arthur Shorin.
- Ryan Schinman.
- [Gary] Ryan, when we first met...
Mark's the real star. He's
building a huge fuckin' business.
Ryan's just stepped in his shit.
Ryan, when we first met,
what was the common interest?
- Basketball cards and baseball cards.
- Guess what his father
and uncles founded?
- Not Topps?
- Yeah, sure.
- [Gary] Can you fuckin' believe this?
(laughs)
- You wanna know what I
brought him as a present today?
So I just bought into a huge...
- Is this the craziest?
- I have a company called Goldin Auctions
now with Ken Goldin so I
bought into that company,
and I actually brought
Gary the new catalog.
- Thank you.
- Wait.
- And then I bought him,
you'll laugh, this today.
- Oh my God.
- Whad'ya know.
- I just gave him a, ya know.
Since that was a present.
- [Arthur] Tell Kenny I say hello.
- [Ryan] I will. You wanna know
what was very interesting...
- Piernoff's a good dude.
- Yeah.
(emotional string music)
I could sell anything.
I can sell everything, anything,
any time, always, forever.
Vlog, I promise I'll start
talking more about sales.
(photo shutter snapping)
(ethereal music)
It's interesting. Here's what I would say.
First you have to know
what your finish line is.
I would actually say knowing
what your finish line is
is the most important part.
Like, I really mean that.
When I think about business in general...
So for example, if your
goal is to sell this
to (redacted) because you
guys are both at a point
in your lives - you're still
young - where you want this
to be the, and I don't know
enough about your business,
but this to be the holy fuck
(redacted)-million dollars each off the...
Well, then you have to know that
and then I would say everything
has to stem from that.
I think the difference
is the fucking execution,
but I would hire somebody
who has sold a brand.
I would pay somebody (redacted)
with the current state of the union.
Meaning whoever just bought
(redacted), so they're out.
They just bought (redacted).
They're not gonna buy it.
Here's (redacted) situation.
Here's (redacted).
Here's an emerging thing.
Here's these two guys who broke off
and got a billion in funding,
and you literally fuckin'
reverse engineered them.
I think the best piece of
advice I could give you
was my opening line
which is, "Okay, cool".
The other line I would tell you is
how big is your ambition to sell.
The one thing you guys
have to with each other,
the most important part, is
tell the truth to each other.
What would get you off the table?
And you should do it on the
first day of January every year
or Christmas or when you
do your end of the year.
If you're aligned on that you could
create incredible business opportunities.
- Could I just interject
here for a second?
I want you to see...
- Oh my God. Who's that?
- That's my 13 year old daughter.
- 13?
- My 13 year old daughter.
- That's amazing. 'a-va' or 'ah-va'?
- 'A-va'.
- 13?
- 13.
- I've been telling you
man, what I've been doing.
I'll explain to you why
that happened real quick.
Ava, right?
Ava, what's up? It's Gary Vee.
I'm hangin' out with your pops.
But I'm telling him that we should
hang out one day so I can't wait for that.
Keep doin' your thing.
Thank you for watching.
I hope you have a great
night. See you soon.
(laughs)
- You do realize that she has
to go to bed tonight, right?
- By the way based on what I
heard on the philanthropy kick,
I'll actually go here first.
I never start with this because
this is super altruistic,
but what I am up to right
now, and Iris will tell you,
literally, and this is so audacious.
I'm basically taking 13,
15, 17, 18 year old boys
and basically winning
the cool game with them.
And I mean number one. Above Curry.
Above, like, winning. Their number one.
Because entrepreneurship has been put
on such an extreme pedestal.
Killy, this hot rapper in
Toronto who I'm friends with,
I basically am in a crazy place.
And one that you couldn't imagine.
Stick with me. 13 to 18.
Not what you see. What he has
some indication to clearly.
But here's where it gets really good.
I'm basically convincing these
children, these young people,
that kindness, empathy,
gratitude, work ethic,
not champagne - you'd be
mad at me - no champagne,
no girls, no private jets.
- I love everything you're talking about
until your 14 or 15.
- But really, on a very serious note,
my ambition for my
legacy has, no question,
taken a step forward
because I've basically
convinced myself, and this
is maybe selling myself,
but, my God, if I can convince
seven to fourteen million young men
that the new cool is the
things that I'm about,
these emotional intelligence skills,
while still being an alpha, oof.
I could have a very real
impact on the world.
I really mean that, by the way.
- I believe it, and he,
for him to say to me,
at the last dinner we had, and
we haven't had many dinners.
He's like, "My daughter was showing me
"this thing about Gary Vee..."
- Is it Instagram with her? YouTube?
You're not sure?
- YouTube. She knows that I
identify as an entrepreneur.
She is always starting things.
I'm always telling her how to do thing.
Not necessarily how to do
the things she wants to do,
but how to do things, and
she found you somewhere on...
- Where I play.
- Where you play.
- And where they play.
- And she spends her time.
And she fell in love with your motivation
and with your talks and
with your messaging.
And I said, "Alright".
And you know I got from her the other day
what I expected to get from her
which was nothing that I would find
necessarily useful about you
except how she connects to
you which I found fascinating.
- A couple things played out for me.
I ended up with two interesting talents.
One of a communication style that
can penetrate a noisy world, and two,
with a disproportionate understanding
of distribution of attention.
Muhammad Ali is Muhammad Ali
because he understood where attention was.
People don't understand how
legends are actually born.
It's not just the quality of your content.
It's understanding when
the medium changes.
Literally, this is data.
Madonna, Michael Jackson, and Prince
were the most all in on MTV.
So for me it's like a spooky...
By the way, I'm always talking right now
as the agent of the human than the human.
I associate more with the
architect of what I'm doing.
I mean, 15 months ago I'm like,
"Fuck it. I'm gonna get every
13-18 year old in the world."
That's basically what I said.
I literally had a meeting
today and was like,
"I'm gonna win India."
And literally, remember
this, in 22 months,
I'm gonna be like, "I'm
fuckin' huge in India."
And here's why and what and how.
It's super interesting, but
I think one of the things
that is super dangerous is allowing
any emotion or ideology to dictate,
in the face of very black
and white, human behavior.
I have never fought the
system of the human being
even at my own peril and that
has made me very successful.
There's a lot of things I don't
like about the human being,
but fighting it is a really big mistake.
I think you have to be thoughtful
about where we are in the life cycle
of the middle man becoming
the internet to everything
and how that plays out.
(emotional music)